من قال انه الامل انقطع فهو واهم لانه في
التوه لحظه قبل دقائق من الان تم اخراج
ناجيه من تحت انقاذ هذا المنزل بعد مئه
ساعه
استمرت فيها تحت الانقاض بدون غذاء بدون
دواء وفي برد قارص وتم اخراج جثه اخرى
فارقت الحياه ولكن السيده التي خرجت
العشرينيه كانت مستيقظه ولكن متعرضه لرضود
كثيره ولكنها على قيد الحياه وهذا
خبر عظيم وجميل جدا بان الامل لازال قائم
نايف في العثور على احياء تحت الانقاض كما
قلت لك في مباشر سابق واكرر الان العمليات
عن عمليات الانقاذ مستمره والبحث عن ناجين
مستمر وهذا الامر يتحقق الان بالفعل هم
نجحوا في الوصول الى سيده عشرينيه هنا في
هذا المبنى والان يبدو انهم يعتقدوا بان
هنالك شخص اخر لا يزال على قيد الحياه
داخل هذا المبنى